let's talk a little bit about money in
elections in the United States and the
various actors that might be involved
you of course at the center of the
action
you have the various campaigns for the
candidates then you have the party
committees that will try to influence
the election and we'll talk about how in
a little bit you have individuals who
besides being voters can also be donors
and then you have organizations
it could be corporations it could be
interest groups
it could be labor unions and then last
but not least we have these two boxes
where you see PAC 1 and PAC 2 and so the
obvious question is what is a PAC well
it stands for political action committee
and they've been around for decades and
a simple way to think about it is it's a
way to pull resources which then can be
donated to other parties to influence an
election but how can the money actually
flow well as you can see it can flow in
many many many different ways and to
help us understand this I'm gonna
introduce some terminology that you
might have heard before there is hard
money and hard money is money that is
actually regulated by the Federal
Election Committee and there are caps in
terms of how much people can donate to
various parties in general any donation
to a candidate's campaign is considered
hard money so that would be hard money
there coming from the individuals this
would be hard money right over here
coming from that PAC which is pulled a
bunch of money this would be hard money
right over here coming from that PAC to
Donald Trump's campaign this would be
hard money coming from the Democratic
Party to Hillary Clinton's campaign or
from the Republican Party to Donald
Trump's campaign if there's something
called hard money perhaps there's also
something called soft money and you
would be correct there is something
called soft money a simple definition
for soft money is it doesn't have the
regulations that hard money does and so
an example of it would be lets say the
Democratic Party here some of the money
that they spend so I'll just draw some
of the money they spend this part right
over here or maybe some of the money
that the Republican Party spends during
the election it's used for what
known as party building activities to
get more people to join their party or
to advertise about certain issues and as
long as it's done not in coordination
with the candidates campaigns this is
not going to have any limit and so some
of the money that goes from an
individual to a party or some of the
money that goes from a PAC to a party
can also be considered soft money if
once again if it keeps separate from
coordinating with a candidate's actual
campaign and use for those party
building activities
now party building is a pretty broad
definition and soft money has been
demonized a lot because people say well
it's just a way of getting around
campaign finance regulations because
even though it might not be directly
coordinated with a candidate's campaign
it can influence an election in a fritti
significant way now to further
understand this diagram you see these
dotted lines between the corporations or
the labor unions and these political
action committees what does that mean
well a political action committee can be
connected or sponsored by a corporation
or a labor union but it cannot receive
funds directly from the Treasury of that
corporation or labor union but the
corporation can sponsor it can say hey
this is associated with us and it can if
it's a labor union it can go to its
membership and say hey I want you to
donate to this PAC if it's a corporation
it can go to its management team and say
hey let's all donate to this PAC
personally or it could go to its
shareholders and say hey why don't we
all donate to this PAC because this PAC
can donate money to the party or the
candidate that might help influence the
election in a way that might benefit us
or benefit the corporation now an
attempt to limit soft money came in 2002
when you have the bipartisan campaign
Reform Act of 2002 often known as
mccain-feingold who are the two sponsors
in the Senate among other things it
tried to limit this soft money after
this act even this party spending would
have to be hard money it would have to
be subjected to the caps when they are
raising that money it also made clear
that corporations and labor unions
couldn't participate in what's called
electioneering Act
where they're spending money on say
issue based ads with oftentimes the
intent of influencing the election
especially in the run-up to the election
so this was made explicitly illegal as
well but this gets challenged in 2010
where you have this major case Citizens
United versus the Federal Election
Committee citizens united was an
organization that was releasing a movie
called Hillary the movie during the 2008
election and this was a movie that was
pretty negative on Hillary Clinton and
so the argument of the government was
that hey even though this looks like a
movie it's really political advertising
it's electioneering as we as we go into
the run-up to an election and so
Citizens United which is a nonprofit
corporation should not be able to do
this but the Supreme Court ruled in
Citizens United
favor they said as long as they are not
coordinating with the actual candidates
campaigns they are allowed based on the
notion of free speech to directly
participate in electioneering in the
run-up to an election and to a large
degree the Citizens United ruling from
2010 really gutted the strength of the
bipartisan campaign Reform Act of 2002
that act was trying to curtail soft
money that for the most part was going
through parties but now post citizens
united on both sides folks started to
say gee I could start an organization
that pulls money let's call that a PAC
but I'm going to keep it independent
it's not going to coordinate in any
other way with the elections of the
individual candidates and so this is
often referred to technically as an
independent expenditure capac and here
post citizens united I can get unlimited
unlimited funding from corporations or
from individuals that is not regulated
in terms of spending caps and now I can
spend an unlimited amount of money on
electioneering to try to influence the
campaign and because of the power of
these types of independent expenditure
PACs they have been termed
superPACs now the key difference between
a super-pac and a regular pack is that
the regular packs that we talked about
have limitations in terms of how much
money people can donate to them they
actually even can't take direct money
from the Treasuries of a corporation or
a labor union they also had limitations
in terms of how much they could donate
to an individual campaign but they could
donate to a campaign a super PAC on the
other hand can take unlimited amounts of
funds from individuals from other PACs
and it could actually take money from
corporate Treasuries themselves and as
long as they are independent of the
candidates campaigns they don't
coordinate with them they can spend as
much money as they would like so as
always it's really interesting to think
about what is going to be the eventual
repercussions of Citizens United vs. FEC
we've already seen in the 2016 elections
money approaching a billion dollars in
terms of super PAC money what is the
influence that has on the democracy but
a lot of folks might immediately
demonize a super PAC and said hey money
was already in politics and this is just
making it worse we're not you have
corporations that are essentially being
able to directly contribute large
amounts of money we've always had issues
with foreign nationals contributing to
our elections we've always tried to
prevent that but a corporation can have
ownership from around the world even if
it's a united states-based corporation
how do you prevent foreign interest from
showing up through this money but on the
other hand I encourage you to read the
Supreme Court's rulings because they had
some very strong arguments in terms of a
slippery slope if you don't allow
citizens united to publish a movie
saying that it's electioneering at what
point is something a political
organization or a media organization and
the Supreme Court found it very
difficult to regulate citizens united
without going down a slippery slope
where they would have to regulate a
whole set of corporations and media I'll
let you think about it but these
questions are quite interesting